and Russia's military has launched air
strikes on the Ukrainian cities of Kev
and Kar at least five people were killed
and 40 injured when a missile hit a
residential street damaging buildings
and setting parked cars on fire the
attacks led to partial disruptions in
electricity and water supply live to Rob
McBride who's in ke for us talked to us
about the strikes in keev and car ke and
and the extent of the damage
caused
yeah I mean air strikes have been
reported at cities and locations across
Ukraine the uh air alarms here in the
capital in ke were sounded just uh
before 6:00 a.m. local time uh and then
at about first light just over an hour
or so later a series of thunderous
explosions across the capital around a
dozen or so as air defenses got to work
intercepting missiles the Ukrainian uh
the Ukrainian Air Force says that
strategic bombers were detected
launching they they believe cruise
missiles uh but there have been reports
of damage on about four or five
districts across ke in particular in the
Salam yansi District that's quite close
to Central keev where we are here uh
there were reports of falling debris uh
setting fire to some apartments damage
damaging um uh cars also some debris
falling close to a kindergarten with a
number of people being reported uh
injured and hospitalized there have also
been reports of a possibly an unexploded
Warhead being detected and evacuations
taking place there and then also reports
of damage in KH which has come under
attack again nationally the government
here is saying that there have been
reports of around five fatalities from
these overnight strikes with more than
40 people injured yeah and both sides
Rob are continuing their air
campaign yeah I mean these strikes have
continued back and forth pretty
consistent stantly throughout these
winter months uh just around the end of
December and at the turn of New Year uh
here in Ukraine there were some very
large missile and drone strikes on
Ukrainian cities including uh ke and
then in the last week or so we have seen
from the Ukraine Ukrainian side some
longer range drone strikes deep into
Russia into Western Russia and also a
Target such as oil and gas terminals up
on the Gulf of Finland on the Baltic
which is well over a kilometers north of
uh north of the Ukraine's border with
Russia this does seem to be a message
from the Russians that they can strike
targets uh wherever they like uh across
the whole of Ukraine Rob thank you very
much for the updates Rob McBride live
for say in keev